je me souviens clairement
fin de l'été 2010 diamond de taio cruz
qui jouent en rue pitt mon lecteur mp3
le bi parfait pour jouer à world of
warcraft au lieu d'étudier les examens
finaux au cégep je me rappelle que
j'avais appliqué au programme de
médecine dentaire j'avais aussi semi
appliquée au programme de physiothérapie
non je dis stop me appliquée parce que
c'est comme c'était comme l'équivalent
d'un cvg dans la section expérience de
travail avait juste écrit we fuck je
reçois ma réponse refusé en
physiothérapie sans aucune surprise le
mais aussi refusé en médecine dentaire
ça m'avait jeté à terre parce que non
seulement mon application était corée
mais en plus de ça j'avais eu la
meilleure note de mon centre d'examen
pour le test de perception spatiale puis
aussi pour le test de sculptures de
créer cet égard mac auteurs le problème
mais quand elle était terrible bon on va
parler de ce don va équiper le prochain
budget que je ne me souviens pas
excusez moi on va parler de ce dont on
parle c'est à dire mission pour savoir
pourquoi est ce que je voulais aller en
médecine dentaire
un je t'aime j'avais une fixation pour
sur le fait d'abord un salaire élevé 2
j'avais de la cedh et de performance qui
3 j'avais une idée extrêmement claire de
ce fait quoi le succès le succès quand
j'avais 17 ans était d'aller soit en
médecine soit en génie ou soit en droit
bon fait que je m'en veux m'inscrire à
l'université mais je peux pas m'inscrire
au consulat parce que j'ai déjà été
refusée comme je vous ai dit en médecine
dentaire
fait je m'inscris jeu tu me dis qu en
quoi je veux m'inscrire pour pouvoir
monter mes notes qui change et de
programmes à créer puis réalité en
médecine dentaire
je fais que je m'inscris en biochimie
l'étendue de ma réflexion c'était je
regarde mon relevé de notes je suis bon
en biologie je suis bon en chimie mais
je suis poche en maths je suis proche en
physique fait biologie chimie biochimie
voilà je m'inscris programme de
biochimie by la première session de
biochimie s'était exclusivement de la
physique moléculaire j'ai détesté sur
mes notes étaient terribles c'était
complètement en chute libre non
seulement ça mais en plus j'ai réalisé
qu'ils avaient seulement une poignée
d'étudiants qui pouvait pas aussi du
programme de m de biochimie ou n'importe
quel autre bac au programme de médecine
dentaire ce qui fait qu acheter encore
plus loin du but que je l'avais jamais
été
donc on servir de base qu'est ce que je
vais m'inscrire vous savez déjà jeté
poche en maths fait le génie été nominé
d'office la médecine du droit a
nettement savait juste l'air trop
difficile que ça soit les études ou
après
mais il ya d'autres professions qui
ressemble à la médecine qui sont quand
même payante la pharmacie ou la médecine
dentaire j'ai choisi la médecine
dentaire exclusivement parce que je t'ai
habile 2001 puis ça me tentait pas
d'apprendre non pilule à l'infini
affection par sa soeur j'ai choisi la
médecine dentaire pas par intérêt ou par
passion fois parce que je voulais rendre
le monde meilleur quoi parce que je
plais aider les gens nés par défaut
fake je m'en vais je m'inscris en
biochimie c'est terrible un jour à la
cafétéria j'entends quelqu'un dire que
la biologie c'est vraiment facile je me
rappelle avoir entendu verbatim la
biologie c'est juste de parler de
comment sauver des bébés pandas puis de
dessiner des feuilles d'arbres
seul capable de faire ça je m'inscris en
biologie la biologie finalement c'était
pas mal plus que ça j'ai disséqué des
lynx puis des ratons laveurs qui avait
été écrasé par deschamps j'ai aussi
essayé de d'extra les cerveaux de
poissons puis de les broyer pour for
extra la rn message et
on est aussi rapide et mulhouse dans les
montagnes en plein milieu de la nuit
pour mettre des taxes aux oreilles puis
j'ai fait quelque chose que je peux pas
décrire autrement que du waterboarding
de cannor on mettait leur tête sous
l'eau puis on attendait de voir leur
activité métabolique descendre vers
c'est super intéressant pour moi la
biologie qui met notre ont commencé à
remonter au bout de deux ans en biologie
j'avais plus du tout envie de m'inscrire
en médecine dentaire c'était comme déjà
une histoire du passé avec au lieu de
continuer dans cette avenue le j'ai
décidé d'avoir une maîtrise en biologie
mais là mon brevet de maîtrise j'étais
assez simple en quoi ça consistait ça
consistait à induire un stress chez les
truites mouchetées pendant leur période
reproductive pour voir comment ça allait
affecter les troupes de prendre ça chez
les jeunes très bon alors vous allez me
demander comment est ce qu'on mesure des
troubles d'apprentissage et des truites
mouchetées c'est facile qui passent des
semaines a construit des labyrinthes en
plexiglas su motiver des trucs dedans tu
les fais parcourir le labyrinthe pete
mesure la quantité de temps que ça leur
prend en compte le nombre d'erreurs
bon ben je vous arrête le sud par
exemple parce que se posait la question
vous auriez dû poser la question vous
aurez de poser c'est comment est-ce que
tu stresses des mamans entre eux
cette approche du bassin d'eau sort la
truite de l'eau qui tu l'achètes
vigoureusement pendant 30 secondes deux
fois par semaine
après deux ans à peu près de travail
acharné à celle qui est détruite ce que
j'ai conclu c'est que les bébés truites
qui venait des mers brossé et nombre ans
et apprenaient le labyrinthe tout aussi
lentement les zones grises ont
facilement
sauf que je vous demande plus tantôt
parce que j'avais pas juste détruit deux
principes détruites provence et ça
serait bien trop simple j'avais aussi
détruite que j'avais mis du cortisol
l'hormone du stress directement par
leurs moules et si j'avais d'autres
trucs que j'avais pas choquer mais que
j'avais mis de cortisol dans leur zone
pour aller envoyé le stress directement
des bébés truites
ça commençait d'un petit conflit comme
design ça parce qu'en plus de ça toutes
ces femelles là c'était des sorts les
unes avec les autres pour pouvoir
limiter la variabilité génétique mais ça
commence à faire pas mal de truites les
caisses fait quand tu as beaucoup de
fruits de fonctionnaires dans des
bassins pour que le tout t
il de l'ebace sites différents bassins
et dans lequel ce métier truites
bon c'est bon t'es vraiment c'est à
différents bars et dans lequel tu mettes
et rugby ici les bassins sont différents
il y en a là d'accueil et sont plus que
je ne porte pas sens où il ya une
lumière qui est plus proche pis les
truites en tant que tel il y en a qui
sont plus mal que d'autres faut en tenir
compte des analyses le mettez vous dans
la peau d'un jeune biologiste qui est
pas bon en maths comme qu'on a déjà
établi qui se retrouvent avec des
dizaines de fichiers excel comme
celle-là ça c'est un vrai fichier qui
viennent la maîtrise jusqu'à
complètement découragé goethe est
dépassé je savais pas du tout quoi faire
avec ça puis faut dire qu est-ce qui a
dépassé que je t'ai avec un paquet
d'autres étudiants en biologie qui avait
justement choisi la biologie parce qu'on
n'a pas besoin de bons en maths quand
qu'on allait en biologie t toutes les
semaines j'entends quelqu'un dire que
les matches de pl depuis qu on servirait
jamais de ce qu'on avait appris au sujet
personne autour de moi aimer les maths
j'irais même jusqu'à dire que le stand
or c'était de d'arborer fièrement un
badge de haïsseurs de matières du monde
qui se vantent qui aiment pas sur les
maths
pis
en fait c'est ici encore vêtu est
d'actualité je suis tombé là dessus la
semaine passée en biologie c'est pas
quelque chose qui me surprenant ne pas
aimer les maths pim aussi jeté un
biologiste fait que ce n'était pas ma
job d'analysé m'est donné c'est ce que
je me suis dit c'est que j'allais aller
voir un statisticien quelle analyse et
toutes mes affaires de maîtrise pour moi
mais ma directrice de recherche était
vraiment pas d'accord avec ça ce cas me
disais que c'était ma job d'apprendre
d'analyser mes données puis ça faisait
partie de mon cheminement donc à me
prêter un livre de statistiques ahmad
une bonne tape dans le dos une coupe de
conseil de me laisser aller
puis je vous dire que après six mois à
ma grande surprise j'avais non seulement
appris à programmer mais j'avais aussi
appris les concepts fondamentaux des bio
statistique je conseille vraiment à à à
et mes soeurs et à comprendre de quoi on
parle et
à la fin la maîtrise j'avais
fini que j'avais réussi à faire mes
analyses qui je pouvais dire que j'avais
une nouvelle corde à mon arc mon arc de
biologistes
bon pour le doctorat j'ai décidé que
j'allais laisser faire les lits brossage
détruite parce que c'est intéressant
mais certaines limites puis j'ai décidé
de me tourner vers la santé humaine
plutôt juste aller en médecine
régénératrice bien génie tissulaire
mon projet c'était d'essayer d'améliorer
les techniques avec lesquels on cultive
et les cellules souches pour faire la
peau pour les patients et grands brûlés
le processus commence à marcher si on
met sera extrêmement simple on prélève
un petit morceau de peau chez un patient
brûlé évidemment un morceau pour ce qui
est pas brûler on sait par l'épiderme du
derme et ensuite de son os cultive dans
un milieu de culture les cellules de
l'épiderme et du derme sur les milieux
de culture c'est comme un cocktail de
celles qui de molécules qui vont
alimenter les cellules si on veut on
appelle les feuillets dermique on
suppose donc encore une fois des
cellules épidermiques sur le dessus et
voilà on a de la peau by lamela
reconstruite humaine qu'on peut greffer
sur des patients brûlés au bout d'une
cinquantaine de jours dis moi ca c'est
ainsi que je m'intéressais
comment est-ce qu'on pouvait optimiser
ce processus là
on a des pistes
on pensait que peut-être la méthode ça
serait bien que la méthode mais là je me
sens vraiment simple pourquoi on se perd
dans les détails et on pensait aussi que
la molécule x pouvaient donner des
marges d'utopia molécules y organiser
ces simples expériences le tout ce que
tu as far s'est comparé à ab puis
comparer et que ça y est pourquoi tu as
besoin de faire un doctorat là dessus
pis c'est là que j'ai réalisé qu'ils
avaient quelque chose qui avait changé
en moi parce que c'est ce qu'on m'a
proposé comme premier projet mais je me
suis demandé qu'est ce est ce que c'est
possible que la relation entre explique
greg dépendent de quelle méthode
qu'utilise là où l'habit est ce que
c'est possible aussi que c'est une
tradition le change tout dépendant de
wes que les cellules viennent sur le
corps humain qui est ce que c'est
possible de faire tout cela en une seule
expérience comme ce fait le moins de
travail possibles puis gratuit le plus
vite possible bien ce que c'est possible
que j'étais en train d années une
expérience qui était ultra complexes à
analyser au niveau statistique pour le
fun
fait qu après c'est après que j'ai
présenté ses résultats aux gens dans mon
laboratoire j'ai commencé à me
rapprocher les gens commencent à me
demander aux mais est ce que tu me dis
que tu es le projet ou un tel projet que
ce soit des chercheurs ou des étudiants
et c'est là que j'ai réalisé que d'avoir
une perspective d'un biologiste qui
aimait pas les maths c'était vraiment
intéressant pour parler de
biostatistiques à des biologistes qui
aiment pas les maths
tour à tour de projet en projet les gens
me demandez est-ce que tu mènes avec ça
j'ai tout le temps oui oui je peux faire
ça pas de problème
des fois c'est vrai mais la majorité du
temps il fallait que j'aille sur youtube
ou regarder des vidéos il fallait que je
lis des articles scientifiques il
fallait aussi que j'arrive publie dans
des forums au fil du temps les
biostatistiques sont devenus un parti
d'une corde à mon arc a plusieurs cordes
à mon arc puis aussi la flèche puis
aussi le carquois qui le cheval pie la
cible
je faisais presque exclusivement saada
biostatistiques on me demandait de
donner des formations telles que j'ai
commencé à des déformations dans mon
centre de recherche qui savent bien à
donner parce que on ne fume pas mais
peut-être donné un cours à l'université
aussi bien suite de ça on a commencé à
approcher d'autres centres de recherche
on y avait des étudiants se retrouver
dans la même situation que moi je
prépare ma maîtrise c'est à dire avec un
paquet
fichier excel puis pas beaucoup d'amour
pour les maths
j'ai commencé à faire d'autres projets
je travaille dans des projets de
parasitologie je travaillais en
réadaptation physique je travaillais en
même en écologie du plancton
dit éventuellement
éventuellement après avoir travaillé
dans toutes ces projets là j'ai décidé
que
j'allais faire plus de biostatistiques
finalement à la fin de mon doctorat j'ai
réalisé que mon nom se retrouvait
presque sans effort dans une trentaine
d'articles scientifiques ça pour une
référence pour ceux qui sont pas
habitués avec les articles scientifiques
si 27 de plus que la moyenne de doctorat
j'ai aussi réalisé en même temps que
j'aimais pas tant le sol est je vais pas
te j'aime pas ça tant que sur la
biologie j'aimais vraiment plus et
biostatistique ça veut dire qu'ils
amendent et pris 11 ans réalisé que
j'aimais vraiment plus que je
considérais comme un hobby que ma job
qu'est ce que je faisais rire
essentiellement toute la journée
aujourd'hui je suis rendu
biostatisticien officiellement sans
aucune formation officielle j'ai pas de
diplôme mais je travaille ensemble de
recherches comme du statisticien à 100%
je considère que si la selas je
considère que ce qui était une corde à
mon arc est devenu ma carrière une
carrière que j'ai choisi un peu par
essai erreur mais surtout par passion
que ce soit pour essayer des exemples de
terminer c'est comment les inégalités
socio-économiques ont affecté les gens
pendant les conflits monaco vide ou que
ce soit pour investiguer les différents
facteurs qui sont associés à la
consommation de drogues chez les jeunes
si je sens que les projets de recherche
dans lequel sont impliqués sont vraiment
importants il sent que je fais une
différence avec 7,7 emploi leur disent
qu'il faut considérer pour demain pour
vous c'est que la plupart des gens qui
ont un diplôme officiel en statistiques
en mathématiques vont souvent aller dans
des carrières qui sont plus payantes par
exemple en assurance ou en finance fait
que je considère que j'ai la chance de
faire ce que je fais
en grande partie parce que les
biologistes mais aussi beaucoup d'autres
scientifiques dans des disciplines
connexes ont décidé que les
mathématiques ce n'est pas pour eux
peut-être un peu trop vite
j'ai pas l'impression que c'est quelque
chose qui va changer non plus dans les
prochaines années je vous rappelle que
j'ai vu ça sur un groupe facebook de
biologistes la semaine passée
fake
si vous aussi en ce moment vous arborez
le badge de ice heures de maths
maintenant ou même dans le futur je dois
vous inviter à vous souvenir de moi le
biologiste qui est devenu
biostatisticien qui aiment pas les maths
qui pensaient qu'ils n'aiment pas les
maths mais qui pensait aussi que dans
une mare de taio cruz une bonne toune
merci
[Applaudissements]